mr. Kennedy it is a great honor to be
with you today talking about your your
your book the persistence of the
color-line racial politics and the Obama
presidency mr. mr. Kennedy could you
talk to me we start out in the book with
race the historical perspective of race
can you start out with how race played
in this country from slavery to Jim Crow
to civil rights well one of the first
things that I wanted to do in the book
was to explain to people frankly why was
it such a big deal on election night
when Barack Obama was elected president
United States I mean why were there
parties all across the United States why
was there this weeping now anytime a
presidents elected you know it's a big
deal and there is emotion but clearly
this time there was something very
different something very special going
on why was that well one reason for that
was this was the first black president
and you know so what's the big deal with
that well one of the things I wanted to
show was the degree to which black
Americans have been marginalized have
been snubbed have been excluded from
electoral politics so I thought that it
would be useful for readers to know
about that history it would be useful
for readers to know for instance that in
the history of the United States there
have only been two popularly elected
black governors Deval Patrick in
Massachusetts and Doug Wilder in cotton
not Virginia in the history of the
United States there have only been three
popularly elected United States senators
Barack Obama from Illinois carol
moseley-braun from from Illinois and
again from from Massachusetts it'll come
to me and in just a second
Edie Brooke Wade Brooke the first
popularly elected for my strategy no
you know one thing people talk about
reconstruction you know during the
Reconstruction era in that in the 19th
century it was legislature
legislators selected who would be the
senator so it was the legislators who
selected the senators that's why I say
this was and there were blacks who were
elected by legislators to go represent
their states in the Senate in fact the
first and one of the most interesting
stories I think in the book is the story
of Hiram revels who was the first black
to represent a state in the Senate now
the thing interesting thing about Hiram
revels is that Hiram revels was selected
by the Mississippi legislature to fill
the seat that had been occupied by
Jefferson Davis Jefferson Davis had been
the president of the Confederacy and
then the Mississippi legislature chose
Hiram revels a black man to fill the
seat that had previously been occupied
by Jefferson Davis and then again I
talked about this in the book right when
Hiram revels goes to represent
Mississippi as a as a senator a
Reconstruction era senator there's a big
debate on whether he can be seated
because some take the position that he
cannot lawfully be seated because after
all before the promulgation of the 14th
amendment in 1868 blacks could not be
citizens of the United States according
to the infamous Dred Scott decision and
so there was this big fight well has he
been a has he been a citizen of the
United States long enough to fulfill the
requirements to be a United States
Senator and there was a big fight and
finally he was seated but there was a
big fight about it and so I thought that
all of that history would be useful for
readers to understand as a way of
appreciating just why it was
that the election of Barack Obama was so
momentous and why it meant so many so
much to so many people particularly
black people I talked out shopton that
long ago and he said we have no model
for this and ie the tears the pride but
at the same time we have to hold this
president accountable and within the
pages of this book you talk about those
who hold this president accountable
could you talk to me about your grade
for this president at this point in time
you're very critical of him you talk
about how race is strategically placed
for him how he is acceptable for whites
but yet he has not gravitated as much
towards the african-american community
could you talk to me about that sure
point number one being president United
States and it's an extraordinarily
difficult job for anybody anybody that's
point number one an extreme because it's
an extraordinary here that you are the
most powerful single individual in the
world you plop us on them and so it's
gonna be difficult for anybody
now here comes Barack Obama two wars
going on an economic catastrophe a
politically divided country and and and
he's a black man now that is you know so
for purposes of level of difficulty you
know I think about athletic events you
get points for levels of difficulty the
level of difficulty is very very high
and that must be appreciated when it
comes to judging the president now as
you know from my book I'm critical of
the president along a wide range of
dimensions and I don't have any problem
with voicing criticism of the president
at the same time when one voices
criticism of the president one must
understand the difficulties he faces
including the special
difficulties he faces because of his
race Barack Obama had to overcome his
blackness to become president of the
United States he has had to overcome his
blackness to effectively govern the
United States and well he will have to
overcome his blackness and yet again in
order to be reelected
so you know I'm happy to go into various
issues I'm happy to voice criticisms to
the president but it has to be against
the backdrop of the special difficulties
that he faces and it's interesting you
have such a special perspective from
this president you were invited to the
wedding you are a harvard law professor
President Obama was a student at Harvard
firstly the Michelle Obama was your
research assistant yes she was you were
invited to the wedding unfortunately you
didn't make it but can you talk to me
about that special relationship and
wrestling with this kind of book well
first of all I I wouldn't say that I
have a real special ID you know I knew
of Barack Obama when he was a student
the reason why I knew of him as a
student and saw him and and you know we
I think we talked a couple of times when
he was a student one reason why I knew
of him is because he was a quite
outstanding student he's president of
the Harvard Law Review the first black
president of the Harvard Law Review you
know several of my colleagues talked
about this remarkable student they had
Barack Obama I mean he you know I mean
that's a very unusual thing I mean there
are a lot of smart students at Harvard
Law School very smart very outstanding
he really did stand apart so I knew of
him in that way the first lady Michelle
Obama I knew a [ __ ] she went to
Princeton I went to Princeton so when
she you know came to Harvard Law School
we met she was very impressive student
very very well organized she did some
research for me I have not really stayed
in touch with them you know in the in
the subsequent years I've admired them
from afar but I'm not really you know
part of their circle
I thought of maybe us trying to seek to
have an interview with the president for
this book I decided you know not to
pursue that reason I decided not to
pursue that it was because I thought
well you know if the president gives you
an interview the president is is
essentially giving you a favor and I
didn't want to I didn't want to feel I
didn't want to feel you know beholden at
all even the least little bit I wanted
to feel completely distant I wanted to
feel like I could say what I thought
without any inhibition and in my book
you know from for whatever it's worth I
felt uninhibited in putting forth my
point of view well just as a reporter's
position and for the last 14 years
covering the president when you
interview him we gain more perspective
from his insights and you have
intensively researched columns and and
and those who have been for and against
and in going back in your book as well
you've you've used examples as FDR and
JFK now how do you link FDR with
President Obama when he wants to reach
out to Abraham Lincoln he was the team
of rivals and things of that nature and
how do you link him to JFK well first of
all I mean for purposes of writing this
I did research on the presidency all the
presidents I want I was I was interested
in knowing well we have the first black
president and people are going to talk
about his relations with you know with
black America you know what about George
Washington what about Thomas Jefferson
what about Polk you know what about
Lincoln what about you know so I went
through them all and many were slave
owners many the many were slave owners
that's right
many were slave owners and not only were
many were not only were they slave
owners they were slave traders you know
and you know Jackson
particular comes to mind he was a you
know unembarrassed participant in in
slavery there were people who brought
their slaves to the White House yes so I
go through the various presidents there
were a couple that you mentioned that I
thought were it was particularly useful
to call upon so even before Obama
occupied the White House people were
making analogies between Obama and FDR I
think one of the reasons is because both
assumed the presidency in the midst of
financial crisis so this you know the
Great Recession people say you know this
was the biggest you know downturn in the
American economy since the Great
Depression well you think Great
Depression Franklin Delano Roosevelt
well okay
in the New Deal and the New Deal so what
about what about Obama
how does he you know so I try to use
analogies I try to compare and contrast
with FDR I came across one interesting
thing people think about you know FDR so
here's a president you know 1930s 1940s
I point out that for much of Franklin
Delano Roosevelt's presidency there was
for much of his presidency he was never
questioned by a black journalist because
when Frank for most of the time that
Franklin Delano Roosevelt was president
there was a rule that allowed only
journalists from daily newspapers to
question him now
the White House made you know he made
exceptions for certain journalists but
not for black journalists and I talked
about in the book how it was that black
journalists finally got to question the
president what happened was that the
president was seeking of FDR was seeking
re-election and he went on a he was
campaigning in Harlem and one of FDR's
chief lieutenants got in a scuffle with
a black policeman and actually
need the policeman in the groin and
there was this you know this this caused
a this caused a minor scandal and - and
and people asked the policeman well
given what's happened are you still
going to vote for FDR and this policeman
said yeah I'm still gonna vote for FDR
I'm still a loyal supporter of FDR's
well this lieutenant of the presidents
who had assaulted this police officer
said says to himself and to others you
know we need to show in some way that
we're sorry about this and the way in
which they showed that they were sorry
about this was to make it so that a
black reporter could question the
president and it was during it was that
episode that was the entering wedge for
black journalists to be able to even
question the President of the United
States in you know in press conferences
that's an amazing fact now you got yeah
with my students yes and I talked about
the 1930s of the 1940s or even the 1960
some of them look at me as if I'm
talking about the age of you know
dinosaurs or something but the 1940s
clearly was not that long ago I talked
about John F Kennedy a good bit in my
book because I thought that it was
useful to compare and contrast Obama and
John F Kennedy John F Kennedy had a
special burden when he ran for the
presidency what was his burden who's
Catholic there had never been a Catholic
President of the United States he had a
special burden he had to go the extra
mile in a swaging the anxieties of non
Catholics who were going to be deciding
whether they should vote for him and he
went he took he went he took special
effort to say that he was not going to
be subservient to the Pope when it came
to things political
he had to make a special effort to show
that yes he was going to recognize the
the wall between your church and state
he had to make special efforts to do
that just like Barack Obama had to make
special efforts to assuage the anxieties
that some non black people were gonna
feel in the in the you know in facing
his candidacy he has made he made and
has made special efforts to show that
you know he wanted to be president of
all the people now that he is president
of all the people that he's not going to
engage in any sort of racial favoritism
that's what I say that you know he had
to overcome his blackness this was a
special burden just like John F Kennedy
had a special burden these Avi his
Catholicism Barack Obama has had a
special burden visa be his blackness in
your book chapter four the race card and
the campaign of 2008
why didn't john mccain use the race card
towards the end of their campaign and we
know that race is political suicide for
many why didn't john mccain use that to
his advantage yeah no you know there are
some people and this is still recent
history with various interpretations
there's some people who claim that you
know the mccain campaign did play the
race card my own view is that the mccain
campaign did not play the race card
nearly as much as they could have john
mccain though he wanted to become
president in nine states did not pull
out all of the stops in his fight for
the white house in my view he is to be
congratulated for that and i don't think
he has received the the congratulations
frankly that he ought to get he could
have done a lot more to try to stir up
racial anxiety racial resentment he did
not why it's not altogether clear some
people have speculated that he didn't
because he
he calculated that it would be
ineffective and that in fact it might
backfire on him I'm fully willing to
believe that you know probably that that
may have been part of his calculation my
own sense is is is a bit more generous
toward John McCain my own sense is that
John McCain did not want to pull out all
the stops he wanted to be President he
wanted very much to be President but he
did not want to be President in that way
he did not want to engage in
you know racial dirty tricks to increase
his chances of being President and I tip
my hat to him you know I'm in you know
for my book I'm very critical of John
McCain I'm especially critical of him
for his selection of a running mate I
don't know Sarah Palin I'm extremely
critical of him for that selection and
I'm critical of him you know for various
other things so I'm not it's not like
I'm a I'm a McCain supporter but I do
think that with respect to the way in
which he ran his campaign I do think
that he thought that it would be a bad
thing for him to engage in a you know
concerted campaign of you know racial
political dirty tricks and like I said I
don't think he has gotten the
recognition that he ought to receive for
taking that position we can't talk about
the race card with John McCain without
talking about the race card with Barack
Obama then presidential candidate Barack
Obama there was one specific time where
he came out on race many equated it to
the new version of I have a dream speech
by dr. King we're talking about the time
when he was in Philadelphia and
addressing the issue of his former
pastor Jeremiah Wright yes talk to me
about what you felt when you saw that I
see many people in your book you know
critiquing it what did you feel first
about that speech I felt a couple of
ways about the speech number one I
thought it was a brilliantly executed
political intervention the primary
purpose of which was to tamp and down
the uproar about his long-standing
relationship with pastor Jeremiah Wright
Jeremiah Wright for a couple of weeks
was featured on cable television
mainly saying very inflammatory things
and Cindy Airy things about the United
States but you have to remember this
this preacher was very well known in the
religious community as well he beyond in
the past of Barack Obama absolutely but
he was a very distinguished pastor very
well known so it's certainly within
black communities in Chicago and outside
of Chicago very well-known and very well
respected nonetheless some of his
statements were broadcasts all over the
United States and it caused a real
ruckus President Obama
well then candidate Obama needed to
tamping down this controversy because it
threatened to derail his candidacy so he
produces a speech a more perfect union
speech given in Philadelphia and did it
tamping down the controversy to a very
large extent it did so that's why I say
it's so far as it doing what you know
the candidate needed to be done at that
moment it worked but that speech is
viewed by some as more than just a
speech aimed at a particular moment some
view the speech is one of the great
American speeches so right now and you
know bookstores all across America you
go to anthologies of great American
speeches there are many anthologies that
include this speech now do I think it's
one of the great American speeches No
I do not I don't think it's you know I
mean I think it was a useful political
speech for an immediate purpose but do I
think that the Barack Obama is a more
perfect union speech for instance should
be on the same page with Martin Luther
King Junior's I have a dream speech no
with all due respect to the president
that his speech in Philadelphia does not
belong on the same page does not belong
it frankly in the same chapter with
Martin Luther King Junior's I have a
dream speech I taught in so you know why
well you know frankly so and so far as
I'm concerned the speech some people say
I'm so illuminating I I don't see it
frankly is very illuminating it's it
said things which would seem to me any
you know well-educated Americans should
know about race relations it did not
take any truly controversial bold risky
positions with respect to race I'm not
you know condemning him for that he's an
electoral politician he faces the
discipline of electoral politics and so
you know you don't want to make people
angry I couldn't just you know potential
voters potential supporters you don't
want to make him angry fine I understand
that but you know let's let's just tell
tell it the way it is this is a speech
for instance that takes pains to be non
accusatory the president knows his way
around the English language very well
there's a reason why when he's talking
about the predicament of black people he
goes into the passive voice black people
suffered enslavement there's no talk
about who was doing the enslaving that
would require pointing and accusatory
finger
white America black people suffered
under Jim Crow segregation until frankly
relatively recently in American history
they suffered under this suffered under
this is this something that you know did
did this the Jim Crow segregation come
from Mars
no there were you know there were people
who were doing the oppressing but but
you know candidate Obama doesn't talk
about that now again I'm not condemning
him for that rhetorical decision it was
probably the a proper decision for a
candidate to make but we ought to
recognize what's going on and one of the
reasons why I want us to recognize
what's going on is because it shows that
even a person he was a senator when he
was running for the presidency he wasn't
just some ordinary Joe he's already a
powerful person in American politics
even a person who's a senator even a
person now who's present in the United
States faces a predicament when they
talk about race they face all sorts of
predicaments they face the fact that
there are some an appreciable number of
Americans who are racially prejudiced
they face the fact that a much larger
portion of the American populace wants
to deny the realities of race even now
and you know as a candidate he had to
grapple with that and you know he had to
get past it he got past it by you know
equivocating he got past it by sort of
engaging in my view in euphemism fine
you know he's a political candidate
that's what political candidates do but
let's recognize the speech for what it
was let's deal with it realistically at
least in my view that's how I viewed the
speech and that's how I continue to be
the speech did this president solidify
the
black vote with that speech and what did
he do for white America who was on the
fence about this young candidate who was
on a fast track to move up well by the
time he gave the speech in Philadelphia
he already had the great mass of black
Americans behind him it's important to
remember initially he was not assured of
the black vote I mean initially there we
had the Clinton machine absolutely and
in fact most of the certainly a you know
most vocal highly-placed
black elected officials were in her camp
not his camp it was only after Barack
Obama broke through in Iowa and showed
that he had a realistic chance of
winning the nomination and of winning
the general election was only after he
showed people hey this candidacy is not
a just a symbolic candidacy this is a
candidacy that is aiming to win the
White House after he showed that he had
a realistic possibility of winning the
White House that's when black voters
really gravitated toward him
so by the time he gets to Philadelphia
the Philadelphia speech black voters
were solidly behind him what he had to
do was continue to shore up white
support and this speech was very
important in him doing that what he was
saying in this speech was hey to you you
know white voters who are anxious about
me anxious about my sentiments anxious
about my background anxious about my
agenda anxious about my allegiances let
me say something to you that will allow
your anxieties and that's what he
proceeded to do and mr. Kennedy the
author of the persistence of the color
line racial politics and the Obama
presidency Randall Kennedy is the author
we'll be back in a moment to talk about
this great book your insights and much
much more
great thank you
on the go afterwards is available via
podcast through iTunes and XML visit
book TV org and click podcasts on the
upper left side of the page select which
podcast you'd like to download and
listen to afterwards while you travel
and we're back with author and Harvard
Law Professor Randall Kennedy the author
of the persistence of the color line
racial policies excuse me racial
politics and the Obama presidency and
mr. Kennedy this is it's been a
fascinating read very interesting as a
reporter I take no sides I just take it
all in but in talking with you moving to
Chapter five and I thought this was very
interesting myself in listening to you
you said it was it was very hard to
grapple with chapter 5 Reverend Wright
and my father talked to me about that
since we just left off with Reverend
Wright talk to me about that well this
is the chapter that concerned me the
most this is a chapter I indicated
earlier that the most perilous moment in
Barack Obama's candidacy was the that
the furor over his relationship with
Reverend Wright and he had to extricate
himself from that relationship he gives
this speech in which he distances
himself but he doesn't cut off forever
right and then Reverend Wright comes
back on the scene and really puts at the
National Press Club at the National
Press and he puts the candidate really
on the hot spot and makes it seem
actually and I thought this was very bad
of Reverend Wright makes it seem as
though maybe the president can de de
Barak Obama was not being completely
candid that he was simply saying things
because you know he was he was seeking
the the White House that he wasn't
completing completely sincere in
distancing himself well at that at that
moment when when Reverend Wright said
that candidate Obama said came back and
said well let me make things clear I am
now cutting off my relationship entirely
with Reverend Wright and in fact he
announced that he was resigning from
that church
where he had been a parishioner for a
number of years well that was a big
moment in the you know Barack Obama
story and I thought I needed to confront
it I wanted to confront it using the
prism of my father and the reason why I
wanted to confront this episode using
the prism of my father is because if my
father had been alive during this
controversy my father would have
completely embraced Reverend Wright my
father's views were very similar to
Reverend Wright's in fact if anything my
father was more extreme than Reverend
Wright more critical of the United
States and then Reverend Wright and I
admire my father my father was a very
loving man a wonderful father a great
parent and I wanted to revisit the whole
Reverend Wright controversy and try to
show people that a couple things number
one Reverend Wright was not some kook
who was a marginal figure I wanted to
show people that you know the ideas that
Reverend Wright had he was in in the
military he was in the military he was
the pastor of a major church and he
facilitated in the operating room for
LBJ door to surgery for Lyndon Baines
Johnson and I yeah that he was very
proud of that yeah he had pictures of
him ministering to Lyndon Johnson when
Lyndon Johnson was at the hospital the
Naval Hospital in Bethesda Maryland
Reverend Wright a marine was you know
assisting with the medical care of the
president so but my father again my
father was actually further over than
Reverend Wright I mean everybody was
talking about you know Reverend Wright
how can he possibly say this and I was
telling my friends listen you know you
should listen to my old man my father
was was more extreme but I wanted people
to understand
again Reverend Wright was not some
marginal figure in black America he
represented a a considerable and
historic stream of thought within black
America and I wanted people to
understand the experiences that would
lead someone of Reverend Wright's
vintage to take the position that he
took and I used my father to help with
that pedagogical purpose my father was
born in 1917 in Louisiana he suffered
terribly under white supremacist
oppression my parents were refugees from
the Jim Crow South I was born in
Columbia South Carolina in 1954 I asked
my parents my father you know why do you
leave my father said straight out he
left the south because he thought that
either two things were going to happen
he thought that either he was going to
be killed whether he was going to kill
somebody and he left it was a very very
perilous time back then absolu for many
African Americans absolutely living on
farms would have he was a he was he was
a postal clerk and and that and that was
a darn good job for a black man in that
air very good job very good you know
what time frame was that this was this
was late 40s early 50s my mother was a
schoolteacher like I said my parents
they they met in Columbia South Carolina
at Fort Jackson they left South Carolina
because my father thought that something
bad was going to happen if he continued
to stay in South Carolina
so he left came to Washington DC raised
three kids three children in Washington
DC we would go back to the south to
South Carolina on holidays and in fact I
talked about at particular episode to
try to bring this to make this vivid I
talked about how at Easter time we would
go back to South Carolina and on at
least two occasions I clearly remember
as a youngster sitting in the back seat
we're going down to South Carolina
police
puts on its lights pulls my father over
police officer white police officer
comes by father says officers or is
there a problem the officer says no I'm
not pulling you over for anything that
you've done wrong but I noticed that
you're driving this nice car and you got
these Washington DC license plates boy
my father's a grown man it's a family
it's white city right next to his
children in the backseat boy I just want
you to know that we do things
differently down south than in
Washington DC I do you know I don't want
you to get in any trouble the police
officer thought that he was doing my
father a favor and he the officer
problem my sense of it was he sincerely
thought that he was helping out he
wanted it you know alert my father that
he had to act differently then maybe he
was used to acting so the officer this
happened twice officer says this to my
father and then he says again he said
you know there's a little there's a
little he says it's to my father then he
waits and I my sense of it as a
youngster was he was waiting to see how
my father would react
my father's reaction was as follows yes
sir I do know that things were done
differently down here I really
appreciate it which you said and then
and my father says this was then with an
extra dollop of deference he probably
did not say yes sir I said I said yes
sir
my father probably said yes sir
that's right my father felt humiliated
by that episode and other episodes
deeply humiliated those humiliations
really scarred my father and he never
got over it when I asked my father later
why he had enlisted in the military in
the 1940s my father did not say anything
about one
to serve his country he didn't say
anything like that I asked my father why
did you enlist in the military my father
said to eat during the during the
Vietnam War my father said to his
friends and neighbors and anybody who'd
listen his position was in his view it
did not make any sense at all for black
people to fight on behalf of the United
States government didn't make sense to
him he he totally embraced Muhammad
Ali's stance so that I could go on with
this but the base commonality is now
viewed as a hero and that's right he's
now viewed as a hero but of course at
the time you know he took a Baptist he
maintained he took a very different
stance my point is that my father's
views were not the conventional
patriotic views and I wanted to alert
reader readers to the fact that yeah
there you know there are black people
who have used that you know that that
like Reverend Wright's
these people are not Kooks they are you
know smart people they are admirable
people they are loving people but they
view the United States differently than
other people in large part because their
experiences now does this mean that I
agree with my father no I love my father
I disagree with various positions that
he that he took just like I disagree
very strongly with various positions
that that Reverend Wright took and I say
that in my book but I wanted people to
understand that the conventional view of
Reverend Wright really simplifies things
and I wanted to make things a little bit
more complex and show Reverend Wright in
a way that I think hadn't been done
before or certainly hadn't been done
sufficiently let's fast-forward
to election night mmm in the victory
speech where were you and who did you
think of ah I was at home watching this
Mike I was surrounded by my three
children and I got telephone calls and I
think that I felt like many people felt
I was you know did I cry yes I did I did
cry and Wow
I cried because I was i I cried because
this was such an extraordinary moment
and on election night just like on
inauguration day you asked me who did I
think about to tell you the truth I
thought of the people who I could not
talk to because they have passed away
you know I thought of mine I thought I
thought frankly first and foremost of my
wife my wife died five years ago my wife
who was a wonderful surgeon went to see
was was was in the audience when Barack
Obama gave his speech at the Democratic
National Convention right that sort of
made him a prince of the Democratic
Party at that time he was I mean he was
he was he was running for his Senate
seat he gave that speech he really
became you know quite a political
celebrity my wife came home and talked
about that speech and talked about her
admiration for Barack Obama subsequently
she passed away she was a person who was
of the belief that she could do anything
and you know she was a naive about race
she knew or naive about gender and the
various impediments and extra burdens
but she believed that she could overcome
those things and one of the things she
loves so much about Barack Obama was she
you know sort of perceived a kindred
soul I can do you can you can do it so
when Barack Obama won the presidency the
fur I immediately thought of my wife I
thought of others who did not live to
see this
I thought of my father who had a very
different view of America that my wife
did but you know I thought my lord here
was a man who for much of his life
had seen the most the ugliest aspects of
America and here was a night that was a
quite wonderful night even people again
if one goes back to the night that
Barack Obama was elected black people
weren't the only people crying there
were white people they were Asian
American people they were Latino people
they were Native American people there
were all sorts of people crying
there were people crying who did not
vote for Barack Obama I have friends who
didn't vote for Barack Obama white
friends who did not vote for Barack
Obama but who were crying on election
night because they said that even though
they did not vote for Barack Obama his
election deeply moved them and even
though they did not support him they
were nonetheless happy about his
election because what because of what it
symbolized and so that's why this you
know that's why that's why people were
talking about you know am I dreaming you
know I had a friend who told you know am
I in a dream it was it it was a deeply
moving night for you know for lots of
people and you know was I deeply moved
yes I was I was deeply moved and I was
deeply moved on inauguration day to with
the crescendo of hope change
anticipation of a new day we have still
have problems with race yeah we have the
beer fest or the meeting with them Henry
the police officer yes and we also had
an issue with the USDA and Shirley
Sherrod in the White House we still have
black unemployment that is almost twice
that of white America in 1963 do I have
a dream speech the black unemployment
was three times that of white America
has the president lived up to the racial
expectations of the black community and
I say that because leading into his
presidency people saw that hope and
change and as a journalist I saw a level
of expectation that I didn't think
anyone could humanly reach is he doing
his job as a regular president or has he
fallen again Barack Obama has burdens
that no white politician would have and
you just mentioned one he had he has
special burdens special racial burdens I
mean white pollicis white politicians
have racial burdens too you know black
people aren't the only people who have a
race everybody has a race but a black
president has a special burden to answer
your question directly I think that
Barack Obama has satisfied realistic
expectations
some people truly did have unrealistic
expectations and there are some people
who you know are really sort of swept up
and had some sort of millenarian hopes I
mean there were some people who viewed
him as a savior they said they
absolutely did there was there was this
there was this sense that the day after
he was sworn in there was going to be a
blood a new blank page and that
everything was going to be completely
different well has he you know has he
fulfilled that no but of course that was
that was those that was a naive
expectation I think if we were going to
talk about black America I think most
black Americans action
they had a more realistic notion they
recognized number one that he was
inheriting tremendous difficulties
especially with the economy they
recognized that as a black politician he
would be scrutinized more than a white
politician with respect to racial
policies and remember there there is
still disproportionate numbers in almost
every sector between blacks and whites
absolutely Hispanic and white absolutely
with rich if we're in every aspect of
American life I don't care if we're
talking about a life expectancy I don't
care if we're talking about access to
medical attention I don't care if we're
talking about employment housing
incarceration you name it and we still
have a racial hierarchy where people of
color are getting the short end of the
stick by and large white Americans are
getting you know a better deal that was
the case before Barack Obama that's the
case now and frankly it's gonna be the
case after Barack Obama leaves the White
House I think most black Americans had
some inkling of that they understood
that and they also understood that with
respect to racial policies detractors of
the president that is say Barack Obama
would have you know they would be
waiting for anything that they could
jump on to say aha
see this black guy is showing favoritism
to black America that's a dilemma are
there people that are you know looking
for any and every opportunity to accuse
the president of racial favoritism the
answer is yes there are there are and to
to combat that the president is very
careful around racial issues in fact he
tipped
around racial issues now some blacks are
critical of him some blacks think that
the president has not been forthright
enough has not been forthcoming enough
has not been militant enough with
respect to racial issues do I think that
they have a point yeah I think they have
a point I think that's an arguable
proposition what I would say though is
he has a special dilemma facing him he's
gonna be he's gonna be criticized if he
goes this way he's gonna be criticized
if he goes this way I think black people
recognize the special dilemma that
Barack Obama faces and in light of that
special dilemma I think that the great
mass of black people are showing a we
are being realistic are being extremely
patient and are giving him leeway given
his special circumstance told me that
race and politics will always follow
this president but why does he tiptoe
around race he tiptoes around it because
it's such a volatile issue you mentioned
a moment ago the the famous beer summit
may recall just as quickly a one of my
colleagues at Harvard University Henry
Louis Gates very well-known academic is
in his house he is coming back from
China he's trying to get in his house a
neighbor's sees two black men you know
trying to push a door to get in the
neighbor calls the police says gosh you
know I don't know if these guys are
trying to break in but maybe they are
you better go check it out by that by
the time the police come Henry Louis
Gates Jr is in his house police officer
says I'm checking this out can you show
me some ID professor gates shows his ID
the police officer still as seems to be
somewhat skeptical one thing leads to
another they have words professor gates
as you know quite upset
things that racial discrimination has
something to do with the police officer
was it arrogance and insensitivity
baby-baby let's suppose the sake of
argument that's that it was that it was
that either the pulled of that Henry
Louis Gates was short tempered and maybe
let's suppose he wasn't being
deferential towards the officer let's
even suppose that he was being arrogant
is being arrogant with respect to a
police officer a crime I don't think so
I hope not and I would also hope that
police officers well-trained police
officers would be trained to deal with
the citizenry and not arrest people
simply because a citizen is let's for
the sake of argument being arrogant in
any event the officer arrests and really
was gates even though the professor had
showed that a this was his house well
this becomes something of a firestorm
there's a press conference the president
has asked his views of this the
President Barack Obama says first of all
I don't know all the facts but given
what I do know am I gonna say this is
racial discrimination no I'm not he does
not accuse the police officer of
engaging in racial discrimination what
he does say is he says it does appear
that this was a stupid action insofar as
the professor had given proof that this
was his house he said this was stupid he
said this was stupid he does not say
it's racially discriminatory merely that
it is stupid
there are people who immediately went on
the attack and accused the president of
engaging in a playing of the race card
to mention one person Glenn Beck
well-known TV personality he says Glenn
Beck said this showed that Barack Obama
has a problem with white culture that
this shows that he's a racist the
president didn't say anything about race
with respect to the arrest he did not
accuse the police officer of engaging in
racial discrimination far from it but
you had a black professor he had a white
police officer he had a black person who
was
arrested there was the immediate jumping
to the conclusion that the Pope that the
President of the United States was gonna
show some sort of racial favoritism so
that ended very badly for the president
the president had to sort of you know
retrieved he had to have this beer
summit invite the police officer to the
White House invest and real and invited
Henry Louis Gates to the White House
that showed how volatile race is let me
give you another example
remember the representative who shouted
you lie yes to the president of
president's addressing a joint meeting
of the Congress about his health care
legislation representative Wilson from
my home state of South Carolina you lie
everybody that was that was viewed as an
attack on the president see absolutely
absolutely
you don't have that and in people of all
political stripes it must be said
Republicans as well as Democrats condemn
that said this was just out-and-out rude
and and representative Wilson himself
apologized question you know was this
racial former President Jimmy Carter
made no bones about it he said yes this
is this is yet another instance of
racial resistance to the president the
President Barack Obama was asked do you
agree with the President Carter would it
Barack Obama say proc Obama said well
representative Wilson disagrees with me
he ought not have shouted out but he has
apologized let's move on in other words
Barack Obama did not want to get mired
in a racial discussion he wanted to
distance himself from the racial
discussion and he did that's the Obama
way of dealing with race in these few
minutes we have left I could talk to you
forever I want to move on into Shirley
Sherrod quickly about that that was not
handled well at all no no that wasn't
handled well and of course the the Obama
administration said
that they did not handle this well as
you know again the agent will call this
was a black high-ranking USDA official
in Georgia right who was accused of
essentially racially discriminatory
discriminating against a farmer who
sought her aid she was speaking to the
n-double-a-cp
people sort of took out certain snippets
of what she said to make it seem as
though she was discriminating against
this white farmer who made it as her aid
as it turned out she helped this farmer
and indeed the farmer came forward and
said that's right Shirley Sherrod did in
fact help me to keep my farm and she
applauded her well because there were
some people in the white house they were
Obama administration fired her because
they were so scared of you know claims
that here there was a you know person in
the administration who had engaged in
some sort of reverse discrimination they
were so scared of that that they jumped
the gun fired her without getting her
side of the story it was a terrible
episode and hopefully the Obama
administration learned something from it
again author Randall Kennedy I thank you
so much for your time and again the book
is the persistence of the color-line
racial politics and the Obama presidency
whether you agree or disagree
it's very thought-provoking it's
interesting and I love stimulating
conversation and this has been very
stimulating conversation but a synopsis
of a synopsis what would you say about
this president now and moving forward
well grace yes I would say that the
central thing about Barack Obama is that
he is a black man who climbed to the top
of American politics and that fact in
and of itself that singular fact is
going to be his main legacy to America
and his main legacy to the world that
fact
shows that things have changed in
America and that things are capable of
even more positive change in America
what would you like to see him do
specifically for the races in this
country particularly african-americans I
would like for Barack Obama to continue
frankly to do what he's doing and that
is to conduct himself in a dignified
thoughtful way I thought I think that
doing that doing what he's doing will
itself leave a an important legacy to
all Americans that all Americans can
build upon author Randall Kennedy thank
you so much thank you thank you for
having me thanks it's great discussion
thank you